[Musique]
l'historique du spectacle c'est une
belle histoire parce que ça a commencé
dans une école où j'ai écrit des
chansons avec des enfants dans une école
de Thiais l'école avec laquelle je
travaille régulièrement et on avait
envie de faire quelque chose sur pour
préparer 2024 avec les enfants donner du
sens ce qu'ils allaient entendre pendant
des années sur le sport le résultat ça a
donné un spectacle qu'on a donné nos
quartiers pour les parents etc c'était
tellement bien que
j'ai envoyé les chansons à l'éditeur qui
fait des livres disques pour enfants et
qui a mordu tout de suite donc c'est
devenu un livre disque c'est la suite de
ce livre disque il y a Virginie de
comète la boîte qui nous fait tourner
qui m'a dit mais ça faut faire un
spectacle aussi et puis on en discutant
on s'est dit que ça pourrait être bien
d'intégrer des acrobates
[Musique]
je vole c'est trop cool c'est les
vacances
à la fois c'est vraiment des chansons et
puis en même temps c'est vraiment du
cirque c'est vraiment du clown donc on a
on a dû chercher moi j'avais jamais
travaillé avec des circassiens des
circassiens n'avaient en gros je jamais
travaillé avec des musiciens donc
fallait qu'on se règle et puis une fois
qu'on a trouvé en vraiment on était
hyper content du résultat il y a un truc
autour du cirque truc un peu clown un
peu le cirque en fait ça mélange bien
tout ça et donc on s'amuse beaucoup
c'est enfin c'était vraiment
une belle rencontre
[Musique]
pas très fan dans l'âme donc je connais
pas forcément les personnages mais par
exemple
Usain Bolt c'est quelqu'un de fort pour
moi moi j'aime le reggae je connais la
Jamaïque je suis allé plein de fois
et lui représente quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire quoi une petite île de
rien du tout elle qui arrive à fabriquer
des coureurs incroyables on n'a pas
toujours pas compris que pourquoi il y a
un truc avec la aussi la l'humeur que ce
mec-là dégage et quelque chose de hyper
positif d'hyper drôle passe on passe au
sérieux il y a des exemples de
détermination de passion de force
mentale qui sont voilà que on avait
envie de parler sur toute ça en fait les
gens avec un cerveau
[Musique]